foreign
[Music]
normally I don't need a mic so this is
good to be here
um everything's fine there's no
emergency
your car's probably okay I would think I
know it's a little strange to have a cop
talking in in uniform at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business but for
those that don't know me here we are
surprise
that's where we're at so let's jump into
this hopefully this all works also we
have a timer that's why I keep looking
down right we were told like stay on
time and I follow directions I'm a rule
follower
so in my over two decades of experience
in in the policing world I've learned
that cops
hate two things the most right
one is change
and the other is when things stay the
same
now as funny as that is that's that's
probably more of a human thing than it
is a police only kind of thing but it is
a thing to consider and like a lot of
the other presenters I am going to talk
about covid
never in my career did I think we were
going to be doing the things that we
were doing and thinking about during
that time and those included things like
large-scale vaccination site safety
security Logistics I never thought that
that was going to be part of my job uh
and then you know some other things that
kind of test values things like what
happens if we're asked to arrest people
for not wearing masks do I have my
officers arrest somebody for not wearing
a mask or not right how do we do that
thank God we didn't have to deal with
that too much but you know that that is
a consideration and then just like other
other organizations right I have
employees I have sworn staff police
officers but I also have non-sworn staff
professional staff and what happens if
they get sick
right they can work from home maybe but
you can't at least for now unless
somebody has a great idea we can't work
Patrol and arrest people from home it's
really hard
uh and so you know how do we deal with
that and then let me give it to you
there's a little twist on that than a
business environment what if I can't
uh what if an entire Patrol team gets
sick
what if my dispatchers get sick and what
if an entire Patrol Division gets sick
and I can't put cops on the street
because I don't have any and I can't
have dispatchers when you call 9-1-1
nobody answers
right these are big issues that again I
didn't think we were going to have to
deal with that but you know get out of
the Doom and Gloom part we actually
found our pace and our Cadence so in
that time in that change in that
challenge we actually found ourselves
doing pretty well and you know people
liked us there were Billboards that said
you know thank you First Responders and
quite honestly that meant a lot coming
in right to see that that was good we
got letters and people sent cookies and
stuff and it was cool a little bit
um
and things were good and and people
waved with all their fingers like most
of the time so we were feeling pretty
good
yeah
let me let me take it down a notch and
then everything changed right the murder
of George Floyd changed everything again
in the middle of a change in challenge
uh communities were angry they were
fearful they were mistrustful they
wanted to know what was going on in
their departments and a human response
not to get all psychological on people
but a normal human response to this and
an organizational response is to kind of
cross your arms and go hey look this
says Mountain View Police Department on
it by the way down the street home of
Google uh
this doesn't say Minneapolis this
doesn't say Memphis right that was those
guys
that wasn't me that was him not me we
didn't do that right
but crossing your arms and doing that
doesn't help
actually it polarizes the argument so a
lot of we'll step out of the Doom and
Gloom again here a lot of
forward-thinking police departments like
my own
showed up we went we were there we
showed up at protests not a security I
mean a little bit but not that's not why
we were there and we went to marches and
we were part of it we were part of the
communication we were listening and we
heard terrible things I mean people were
mad roughly so and you know sometimes
yelling at us but we listened and we
were part of the conversation because
we're part of the community a lot of
police departments have they struggle
with that we're part of the community
the other this is backwards for me so
this here is another program that I'm
very proud about that we started so if
you're all familiar with the Citizens
Academy or a Community Academy Police
Academy that a lot of departments do we
did that same thing we rebranded it
mvpdx because we're cool and uh flipped
it on its head we actually invited uh
seeked out and invited the people who
were showing up at City Council meetings
who were angry who wanted answers and
were demanding action and we brought
them very design thinking into a room
like this actually this is one of the
the cohorts and we talked about those
hard issues right excessive use of force
policing our own transparency racial
bias Prejudice training recruiting right
budgets
and we heard awful things and we got to
learn with them and proud to say that
that is still happening today in fact we
just graduated our our last cohort about
a month ago
so this wouldn't be lead without a story
so here's my story
this is a body camera officer worn
cameras and I probably should have had
one on today my boss is not going to be
happy sorry
um
we bought these for our folks many years
ago right for our officers and I was all
excited about this at that time I was a
newly minted Lieutenant Saul Jaeger and
I was all excited about this to have the
ability to have video and audio
recording of all of our contacts I mean
it was going to be awesome right I was
super super excited about this
and one of my first tasks was to contact
the patrol teams and talk to them about
how we're going to do this expectations
you know all the things that go around
with that now I want to take a minute I
want you guys to think in your minds
take you back for a second all the
police shows and movies that you've ever
seen think about The Salty veterans the
old cops right crooked hat sitting back
you know everything sucks
that was the team that I decided to go
to
like what could go wrong right that's
not this team this is like our new folks
but that was the only picture I could
find quickly
so I went in there and I explained it
and I got crushed like absolutely
crushed they hated it hated everything
about it they were worried about what if
I forget to turn it on what if I forget
to turn it off what if I go to the
bathroom
what if I say a bad word are you Command
Staff are you guys going to yell at me
and am I going to get in trouble right
hated it I left the room I was like
completely deflated I walked out shut
the door a sergeant looked at me peeked
out and said hey what happened I told
him he said come here kid he actually
said kid
and he said listen at one time the only
radio that the police officers had was
in their car here in Mountain View well
not here but here in my city
if they need anything they went back to
the car they made their call or they
they called on a pay phone
the only thing they had was their on
their belt was their gun their handcuffs
a set of keys and a baton and that was
it and things were good they were happy
and things were good and one day a
command officer much like yourself
walked in and said hey guys they were
all guys at the time they were like hey
guys
um we have these new radios these new
portable radios that were like this big
you're going to use these and it's going
to be wonderful and great and everything
and he looked at me and he said Saul
what do you think they thought of that
and again I'm defeated I'm like I don't
know they must have loved it right he
goes no they hated it they hated
everything about it right what if I
forget to turn it on what if I forget to
turn it off it's too big it's too heavy
it's uncomfortable what if they use it
as a weapon against me and the kicker
was oh so now you're gonna call me
anytime you want tell me where to go who
to talk to how to do my job
right
and I was like okay wise Sergeant I get
it here we are today now
this is a this is an organization in an
industry that is very change of verse we
don't like it we hate it
but at the same time everything is
changing constantly in our world
and I just talked about one piece of
equipment that's one thing but think
about legislation and policy and law and
Community sentiment right it changes in
the blink of an eye we saw it with
George Floyd So in an industry that's
staring at change all the time
that hates it we're trying to kind of
spin that so I have a minute left
my challenge to you is two things one is
individual for each one of you how are
you and I don't have the answer to this
but how are you going to wrap your head
around change and reframe it in a way
that you see it as something positive
and is something that is a growth
opportunity and two as Leaders of people
leaders of human beings how are you
going to gently push and encourage nudge
maybe your organization as a whole to
also see change as a growth opportunity
not as something to be feared
thank you
30 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]